ON HOW THEY IMAGES HAVE HELPED
UNCOVER MANY OF THE DRAMATIC AND
TRAGIC EVENTS IN THE WAR.
>> THESE NEW SATELLITE IMAGES
SHOW WHAT APPEAR TO BE THE
RAMPING UP OF THEFT BY RUSSIA OF
UKRAINIAN GRAIN BEING POURED
INTO THE OPEN HOLD OF A RUSSIAN
SHIP.
THIS WAS IN THE CRIMEAN PORT ON
MAY 19th.
THEN, TWO DAYS LATER, A SECOND
SHIP DOCKS AND IT TOO IS FILLED.
NOW, BOTH RUSSIAN SHIPS ARE
SAILING AWAY.
>> GRAINS.
>> THIS WEEKEND, PRESIDENT
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY ACCUSED
RUSSIA OF FUELING A FOOD CRISIS
AND OF GRADUALLY STEALING
UKRAINE'S FOOD SUPPLIES AND
TRYING TO SELL THEM.
AN EARLIER IMAGE FROM MAXAR
TECHNOLOGIES SHOWS ONE OF THOSE
SAME RUSSIAN SHIPS IN A PORT OF
THEIR CLOSE ALLY, SYRIA.
THE UKRAINIAN GRAIN WAITING TO
BE UNLOADED ONTO TRUCKS.
THESE EXTRAORDINARY REVEALING
IMAGES ARE SO CLOSE AND SO CLEAR
THEY LOOK LIKE THEY COULD BE
TAKEN BY DRONE OR HELICOPTER.
>> YOU CAN ACTUALLY SEE THE
GRAIN POURING INTO THE OPEN HOLE
OF THE SHIP.
>> STEVEN WOOD AND HIS TEAM
SPOTTED THE SHIPS IN THIS MUCH
WIDER IMAGE OF CRIMEA.
>> THIS IS 400 MILES UP IN
SPACE.
TO BE ABLE TO SEE THAT LEVEL OF
DETAIL, THE SHIPS, THE CAB OF
THE TRUCK, PRETTY PHENOMENAL
STUFF.
>> MAXAR AND OTHER COMMERCIAL
SATELLITE COMPANIED HAVE PLAYED
A CRITICAL WAR IN WHAT WE KNOW
ON RUSSIA'S WAR ON UKRAINE WITH
SATELLITE IMAGERY THAT IS
UNPRECEDENTED IN QUALITY AND HOW
IT'S BEING USED.
>> BEFORE, THIS WAS ONLY
AVAILABLE IN THE HALLS OF THE
CIA OR THE U.S. GOVERNMENT OR
FRIENDLY FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS.
TO NOW WE'RE SHOWING IT ON CNN.
>> WE'RE KEEPING A VERY CLOSE
EYE ON THAT COLUMN OF RUSSIAN
VEHICLES, THAT CONVOY WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
>> THEY ALERTED TO THE WORLD TO
THE FAMOUS 40-MILE-LONG RUSSIAN
CONVOY OUTSIDE KYIV, THE ROWS OF
HUNDREDS OF MASS GRAVES NEAR
MARIUPOL, POTENTIAL WAR CRIMES
IN BUCHA, AND THE AFTERMATH OF
THE RUSSIAN BOMBING OF THE
MARIUPOL THEATER.
>> THE SATELLITE IS IN THE FINAL
STAGES OF GETTING READY TO BE
SHIPPED VERY SOON.
>> WE WERE GIVEN A RARE TOUR OF
THE SATELLITE FACTORY IN PALO
ALTO, CALIFORNIA, BY THE CEO.
JOINT PROJECTS WITH NASA AND
OTHERS, CONSTRUCTION UNDER WAY
ON SIX NEW MAXAR SATELLITES
WHICH WILL ALLOW THEM TO SCAN A
SINGLE SPOT ON EARTH 15 TIMES A
DAY.
FOR DECADES, MAXAR HAS PROVIDED
ALL KINDS OF IMAGES TO BOTH
PRIVATE CLIENTS AND TO THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
THEIR BIGGEST CUSTOMER.
HOW MUCH DOES THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT TELL YOU WHERE TO
LOOK?
>> THEY TELL US WHERE TO POINT
THE SATELLITES AND TAKE THE
IMAGERY AND THEN THAT'S WHAT WE
FEED INTO THEM AS A SERVICE, THE
SAME WAY WE WOULD DO FOR GOOGP
MAPS, FOR EXAMPLE.
>> WILL THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, FOR EXAMPLE, SAY WE
KNOW THERE IS A WAR CRIME THAT
HAS BEEN COMMITTED.
THERE'S ALL THESE MASS GRAVES,
FOR EXAMPLE.
TRAIN YOUR SATELLITES THERE AND
PUSH OUT THOSE IMAGES TO THE
PRESS?
>> THEY ACTUALLY -- THEY MIGHT
ASK US TO MAKE THOSE
COLLECTIONS.
BUT THEY DO NOT INFLUENCE OR ASK
US TO NECESSARILY PUT OUT WHAT
WE'RE PUTTING OUT TO THE PUBLIC.
>> MAXAR IS NOW GIVING IMAGERY
TO THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT,
PART OF THE U.S. AID FOR
UKRAINE.
IN A FIGHT, THE U.S. AND OTHERS
NOW SAY, THAT HAS RESULTED IN
RUSSIAN WAR CRIMES.
>> TO WHAT EXTENT ARE YOUR
IMAGES GOING TO BE CRITICAL IN
THESE WAR CRIMES INVESTIGATIONS?
>> FOR EXAMPLE, THE BODIES THAT
WERE FOUND ON THE STREET IN
BUCHA.
WE HAD IMAGERY CORRELATING AT
THAT EXACT SAME TIME WHERE THESE
BODIES WERE.
DOWN TO THE PLACE, THE TIME, AND
THE MOMENT.
IT'S HAVING THAT KIND OF
FIDELITY OF DATA THAT WE NOW
HAVE THAT MAKES THAT POSSIBLE.
I THINK IT WILL PLAY AN
IMPORTANT PART.
>> EACH ONE OF THOSE RUSSIAN
CARGO SHIPS THAT WE SHOWED YOU
THERE IN THOSE NEW SATELLITE
IMAGES CARRIES 30,000 TONS OF
GRAIN.
RUSSIA, OF COURSE, DENIES
THEY'RE STEALING THAT GRAIN.
BUT WHAT THEY AREN'T TAKING,
THEY ARE TARGETING OR BLOCKING
FROM GETTING OUT OF THE COUNTR